winning like the nets
amazing season number one rated offense
in the nba
kyrie irving historic season
but the biggest victory for the nets
is yet to come yeah and the big victory
for new york is when you finally leave
[Music]
[Applause]
and yet another scoop missed by woodward
and bernstein
washington post reporter carol lonig
claims that donald trump
didn't want any fat or short secret
service agents on his detail
now that's hard-hitting journalism if
these allegations
prove true not only was president trump
guilty of institutional fat shaming
he also single-handedly crushed the
lifelong dreams of a shy
chunky young lad by the name of brian
stelter
it was a long way for a joke now this is
from a book on the secret
service but the only buzz being
generated is about the most interesting
man on the planet since that old guy who
drinks dos equis
trump according to the book uh trump
once said quote i want these fat guys
off my detail
he added how are they going to protect
me and my family if they can't run down
the streets
you don't even have to add anything to
this so once again someone's trying to
sell a book
based on a conversation that likely
cannot be verified by someone on record
and what happens everyone in the press
calls the same source to verify it
that's their confirmation a
misinformation loop
but we don't do that here at gutfeld
mainly because we don't have the budget
for a phone and i'm really lazy
but also there's no need to because i
believe that quote is 100
factual of course trump would say he
doesn't want fat guys on his detail
cause that's what we'd all say if we
were the president too
he is us we are him
he is right only one of the only reasons
to be president
is the perks this is not a great job
half the country hates you
and you always have to wear a suit and a
tie even a bed
and unless you're a left-wing chill the
media despises you
and you can't even look at a woman
without being accused of something
and even if you do get lucky how can you
be intimate when there are three men
with guns nearby
i mean i can't i practiced a lot in
prison
[Laughter]
and god forbid you want to have a drink
you'll have to put the whiskey in a
juice box which is something
i learned from the gals on outnumbered
[Laughter]
having secret service is perk priority
number one
as president you can do anything hey
let's drive by my old guidance
counselor's house and pelt has used
miata with rotten eggs
and if anyone comes for you the secret
service can shoot them in the face
i think that's in the constitution i
didn't check but i'm assuming
look when i become president i don't
want an agent who looks like a coke
machine with a head i want him to i want
him or her to look like
you know dolph lundgren during the
alleged steroid phase
alleged or carl weathers in the
action-jackson phase
what a body on that huh and he needed
one to fight craig t
nelson nobody remembers craig t nelson
so you need a show of force not a show
of flab
you want clint eastwood not clint howard
[Laughter]
and remember the movie was called in the
line of fire
not in the line of dairy queen
this is why trump was so beloved he'd
say what you would say he didn't lower
he didn't lower any bar he spoke like
you do when you're at a bar of course
trump also didn't want short people
there either
so as a member of that community whose
height has been historically
underrepresented in law enforcement and
also
on dating shows should i throw a tantrum
should i drown myself in a teapot or
hang myself from a bowling trophy
no i get it if you're supposed to take a
bullet for the president
it's kind of unfair if the president is
a taller target than you
that seems like a thing that should be
on the checklist of human shields
is he in reasonably good shape check
does he own a pair of mirrored
sunglasses
check is he taller than peter dinklage
check
of course the service has fitness
standards for agents in the field you
have to be able to run a mile in under
10 minutes
and beat up 10 hippies while riding a
black bear but some agents
they also have office jobs and that's
where i would work
i know my place i can catch a typo but
not a bullet
i'll take one for the team as long as
it's a spiced latte with skim
plus i'd have a really cool secret code
name like sorry ladies he's married
but this excerpt is meant to portray
trump once again as intolerant claiming
he tried to remove staff
he deemed too fat or too short boohoo no
one minded when he enforced these same
standards for the miss universe pageant
telling men who are too fat or too short
that she didn't make the cut
that happens all the time among women
it's known as dating
cat back me up
[Laughter]
all right don't fine i wonder what our
angry white male thinks
[Music]
you know one of the things i learned in
life not everyone can do everything
when i was a kid i wanted to be a
baseball player or a fireman
i guess i'm not suited to either one of
those yeah
there's a lot i can't do but if you want
a guy who can whittle a stick into
something recognizable
i'm your man what do you think
human hand
intolerant jerk i wonder what our angry
black male thinks
[Music]
[Laughter]
what it is what's up
president trump said he didn't want a
short fat guy
as a bodyguard
no new line
so once again the media experiencing
their trademark
trademark trump withdrawal seeks their
next fix in another dopey excerpt
but remember this trump may not be a fan
of imperfect physiques
but he never denigrated the working guy
in law enforcement
you want to contrast try joe biden's
recent comments
commemorating national police week after
a perfunctory expression of gratitude
he noted quote a deep distrust towards
law enforcement which has been
exacerbated by the recent deaths of
several black and brown people at the
hands of law enforcement
he's like a guy with a sore tooth he
just couldn't leave it alone
thanks for that joe remind me not to
have you give the eulogy at my funeral
of course the slandering of the police
seems way worse to me anyway
than wanting reasonably fit people to
protect you in your country
and of course it was trump's insult not
joe's that gets more coverage
do you think trump gives two rips about
what the positive body image crowd
thinks
fat chance
let's welcome tonight's guests
we were worried he wouldn't come back
after cat tried to steal his
prescription pad
post have asked dr drew dr drew
pinsky
he's from the hawkeye state and always
shoots straight
former acting attorney general matt
whitaker
she likes her prince harry fox news
contributor cat tim
he's so huge getting on his good side
takes two trips
my massive sidekick and joseph nuff said
on fox nation kairis
[Music]
all right dr drew we're gonna wade in
some dangerous territory yeah i want to
thank you for that homoerotic opening
well done i mean i don't know what that
did for you but i know my wife enjoyed
it that's right
evidently too so now it's very
disgusting i remember them from bars
though you know okay
you're a doctor or so you claim i've
never seen any proof of this how dare
you
do we have to go there just give me your
prescription pad and
everything will be done um
are people that are overweight or short
physically less capable in this
particular job
yes right i mean people people become
firemen they have to pass certain kinds
of testing when people become secret
service but apparently
they have standards and these guys all
passed it but it does sound like trump
doesn't it really
sounds like him being him where
everybody gets fired if they're not up
to his specific little qualifications
by the way you mentioned the miss
universe pageant yeah i believe i'm the
only guest you ever had that was
actually a judge on this usa pageant
for him oh wow yeah he sat behind me
with melania and uh
it was an interesting experience you're
the strangest doctor i've ever met
thank you for that i i thank you yeah
some dog you know i saved a patient on a
plane well i was a judge on a pageant
you make me sick dr drew you have saved
many people's lives
i kid i kid i know that all right
matt welcome to the show thank you i
know this isn't like those other fox
shows
no it's not plus i'm not remote from des
moines that's the other thing
you right now you you wish you were um
do you think um do you think the
uh president i believe he said this and
you worked with the president
he did i was in his cabinet i spent a
lot of time yeah but
i you understand yes
you notice he went from miss universe to
miss usa or whatever
i you know obviously he likes fit law
enforcement you know attorney general
being jacked
i might add
[Laughter]
you know i think it's important when i
when i had that you know that glorious
moment where i had a security detail of
fbi agents i mean they were all you know
very fit and yeah and
willing to break a lot of necks from
what i could tell so yeah
you know i think it is good and you know
and in the president's defense
it was it's a visual medium right right
and so he wanted to make sure
that he had people that look like me
around him yes no but that that's
exactly right almost
because he is a product of our culture
and a product of television
tyrus uh you are you were a bodyguard
yes i was
yes you know i'm with him i don't have
an issue
with him not wanting short fat guys or
whatever is around him because
being a bodyguard takes a special kind
of dude and
although i did my job to the best of my
ability there was always a little voice
in the back of my head
if they pull a gun quit you know i'm
saying like
don't take the bullet it's just no snoop
i mean i don't even like his music that
much
like gun uh here's my resume and two
somebody could literally yell gun every
five minutes in the entourage you were
traveling with
well that's how you always find out
who's who's really
got it you know and i disagree with the
president a little bit because
and all my bodyguard stuff it wasn't
always the other big guys that i would
rely on i usually work with someone
your size because he could see things
that i didn't oh you mean like the
ground and
those yes and like but i look up here at
heads and he sees bodies he sees
people's waistbands it's important
because you know who's toting and who's
not oh i get it i can see one
guy's got a gun stuffed in the small of
his back or on the side that you can see
it
and then i hear a little voice it's like
thanos allen you pull on my jean like
iris yes greg john oh thank you greg
and then we go get them oh you can
travel on your shoulders
like a little woodland nymph i see a
show
cat do you remember the bodyguards for
gaddafi
do you remember that the hot girls do
you remember this yeah i'll wishes
this is you didn't talk about my
favorite part of this story which is
that apparently these bodyguards were so
hot
yes that tiffany trump broke up with her
boyfriend and started spending a lot of
alone time with one of the bodyguards
and nobody does we don't talk about
tiffany trump enough because i
i'm more and more convinced the more i
hear about her that she is awesome
and like you just said that you know
trump is so ruthless and this and
he is but i think it's nothing compared
to how ruthless tiffany
really i am serious okay and you know
january 19th right for biden's
inauguration
obviously a lot of stuff going on in her
family right
what does she do she goes to instagram
and announces her engagement
to another guy who she met
partying at lindsay lohan's beach club
in mykonos
like drunk may not give a sh but tiffany
gives
no i want to party with tiffany
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else